i i don't know
if the prosecutor says something stupid
can the defense object your honor that's
you know stupid you know what i mean uh
to be fair though like i think so if the
prosecutor says something nonsensical
i'm pretty sure that the defense can say
objection
you know false statement or something
like that i don't know because my
favorite moment in the entire trial and
you guys as gun as gun guys are going to
love it when he said hollow points are
designed to enter the target and explode
inside and kyle just like froze his
brother i don't think that's right and
the judge goes do you mean expand expand
they don't explode like the prosecutor
was saying nonsense he actually the
prosecution made the argument that
because kyle rittenhouse was using full
metal jacket uh he was trying to shoot
through people sure because full metal
jackets designed to go through and i'm
like
where was the defense to cross and say
like that's not true right but the
problem was kyle's not an expert on the
they didn't have a firearms account the
bullet exploding i think what happens it
goes in and then it the pressure causes
it yeah so hollow point bullets usually
have a hollow cavity in the front of the
nose why it's called a hollow point and
what happens when it hits a soft target
if they peel back and they become larger
because you especially with handguns you
have to understand
we use these terms switches and timers
okay so if i shoot you with a handgun
i could shoot you say
in
like
center mass in the face or or in the
chest and that's what we would call like
a switch right instant like like anthony
huber okay he got shot and two seconds
afterward he dropped to the ground why
because he got hit right in the aorta
instant loss of blood pressure and
you're you're dead before you hit the
floor same thing if you get hit in the
brain something like that right we call
the brain box
timers are you know if i shoot you three
times
in uh you know your lower abdomen well
you may bleed out but that might take
five or ten minutes and in that five or
ten minutes you can still kill me during
that time period so with pistol
ammunition in particular because it has
a lot less velocity than rifle
ammunition you want that you want the
hole to be as large as possible so that
they bleed out as quickly as possible
rifle ammunition has some other wounding
characteristics uh which doesn't require
to be as large per se but the funny
thing is 55 grain full metal jacket ammo
which is what he was using
that's what
the military originally specified in the
original m16 rifle and they chose that
specifically because at velocities over
approximately 2600 feet per second which
it would have been at coming out of the
barrel of his rifle
they are designed to uh tumble and
fragment very reliably so could they
have passed through rosenbaum
potentially but they didn't pass through
huber because there was no exit wound on
him they did they worked exactly as
designed so this idea that full metal
jacket is always designed to pass
through somebody is a total misnomer and
that to me was i can't believe that they
didn't have a ballistics expert out
there to explain these things the
defense screwed that up they the
prosecution i believe he said it's this
it's it's did he say it was designed to
to go through pass through yeah and yeah
and the judge called it a steel jacketed
steel jacket right no it's not not
copperjack right and i was just like
you're right the defense didn't have a
firearms expert that was that's insane
to me because kyle rittenhouse could
have said in that line of questioning
where they could have brought up an
expert and he could have said the use of
hollow-point rounds suggests intent to
cause more bodily harm sure in fact by
kyle rittenhouse using a full metal
jacket which is much more of a standard
basic round for this rifle it stands to
reason if the if the round passed
through it would cause less damage and
be less likely to kill they could have
had someone testify that you could argue
that six ways from sunday though because
if i if i let's just you now you have
the issue i use a full metal jacket
round that is not as effective when he
in impacting soft tissue uh at creating
a larger wound cavity so a full metal
jacket round is gonna pat is more likely
to pass through therefore i was not
interested in killing them only
seriously maiming them yeah i mean
that's that's the murder charge it is
still a murder charge but you should
attempted murder i mean that that so
there's risk there right uh what he was
trying to say is that if you were if you
were preparing for over penetration you
were being reckless
but the argument could have been
you know the prosecution's suggesting
someone else should use hollow points
hollow points more likely to cause you
know tissue damage yes i mean if if
banger's a prosecuting attorney he
should be disbarred for this level of
incompetence the the point is he was
being uh written house is charged with
intentional homicide if he said
you know i i it's a standard round it's
it's very basic it doesn't have any kind
of added characteristics we're going
through an ammo shortage
right the the jacket is simply so that
it doesn't put lead deposits in the
rifle the barrel right in the barrel
it's it's basically just to keep keep it
clean and you know i thought to myself
if i use hollow point or any kind of
polymer tip or specialized round that
might actually hurt people more and i
don't want anyone to get seriously hurt
i just want to stop the threat against
me sure that that would that would call
into question the homicide charge they
could he could try and say well you're
being reckless then and i'd say oh
actually like you mentioned the two two
threes will tumble around inside but not
expand so i was actually hoping that you
know if or i wouldn't say we're hoping
but i was i was scared in the event if i
used a more serious round i would take
someone's life and i figured to myself i
don't want to do that so i wouldn't yeah
and people think that this is just gun
people like being pedantic with
terminology you know we hear that a lot
from anti-gun people in particular oh
you guys are so caught up in terminology
rifle pistol
short barrel etc and my answer that is
always a couple things first of all this
is like a common issue that we have to
talk about with ammunition in particular
there are people who uh that that's like
a myth you see on the internet oh if you
if you're a home reloader and you make
your own ammo and it's
a higher power than what you would buy
off the shelf you know if you use that
in a self-defense situation they're
going to use that against you and try to
paint you as some kind of killer so you
should only use
i hear this from a lot of firearms
instructors that you should you should
call your local police department find
out what your local police officers
carry which are almost always going to
be a hollow point of some variety and
that's what you should use because then
if you get up in court you can say hey i
shot the guy with the same thing that
the novi police or the you know whatever
police department uses so i'm in the
clear did you guys see gage gross kroitz
say that two two three is a large
caliber rifle round yes yeah it's a
snake
a firearms expert to be like that's not
true not true
it's actually on the smaller end yeah
right yeah
and lower uh chamber pressure
uh chamber pressure is
you know on par but in terms of the the
diameter of the bullet you know and the
muzzle energy compared to say like 308
winchester or 30 out 6 which you know we
were fielding in world war ii i mean
that you're talking about almost double
the muzzle energy could you imagine kyle
walking around with like a bear at m82
well yeah i mean he'd be ripped right
right
when we went to the range forest
actually held it up you know it's not a
yeah shoulder to go at all
like 70 pounds and you're trying to like
it's yeah it's not it's 70. it's 40.
it's it's it's a heavy gun
without any optics it's about 30. it's
getting it's like i think it was at 27.
how close towards you is the is the
center of mass on that thing not close
it's a heavy bullet you're trying it's a
heavy very the barrel you know
especially on large rifles the barrel is
very thick
so that's where the majority of the
weight in a firearm is because the
barrel has to be able to withstand
especially like long barrel with a with
a 50 bmg if you look at those under a
really high speed camera 100 000 frames
per second you'll see the barrel
wave
so they have to be very very thick and
the steel is very heavy so there we
almost is very heavy we should have
actually grabbed some some rounds to
show yeah i wish we did we don't yeah
like i i literally because we haven't
got one in my car we have the 50 bmg yes
but and that this this is the misnomer
so you know you'll see uh by the way
these are available on our website uh
serialized let's go brandon phoenix
ammunition so you know this is a fiat
this is a 50 bmg cartridge case
but you know the actual projectile
itself and again with the terminology
like being that this is what i do for a
living i say projectile because you know
people will commonly refer to as the
entire cartridge as a bullet
but really the bullet is only the thing
that comes out and so like i've seen ads
from mom's demand action where you'll
see them uh showing the whole cartridge
like coming out of the end of the right
now that's how stupid these people
there's a lot of movies so
i want to talk about something else too
um can we
first cover up the 556-223 question
because yeah yeah
i mean because i think this is this is
actually much more important the the
going back to the r uh kyle rittenhouse
case there are multiple things that are
going on in this trial that the person
who's on trial is actually the american
family like you and i and every
individual person and the first example
of the five five six question or the two
two three right i'm not going to go down
to the arguments on what's the
difference between five five six and two
two three for the remainder of this
conversation they're effectively the
same thing there's a you're talking
about years of change and long story the
two two three round was designed to be
shot out of a 16 or a 20 or 18 16 20
inch barrel a longer barrel so it can
build up muzzle velocity so the things
that impact the effectiveness of that
round are the load that is used the
projectile that is used the rifling of
the barrel the length of the barrel
all of these factors go into play where
you see where in or was it maybe 10
years ago short barreled rifles concepts
became super popular one of the reasons
why the mark 18 has a 10.8 10.3 inch
barrel because is because that's about
as close as you can get before that
bullet that projectile once fired does
not move fast enough to produce what are
they called hydrostatic yeah hydrostatic
shock hydrostatic shock
terminal wounding it's it you're looking
at like
very very detailed stories so when
somebody says that the ar-15 is a deadly
dangerous weapon of war
you are they are
simultaneously being met by veterans
overseas who complained it wasn't deadly
enough using using a 556 rifle with
green tip rounds armor piercing language
out the door were having issues because
the guy was on drugs and would shrug it
off back to timers and switches yeah
that's that's why that's why they made
the the 458 socom right there that's one
of the reasons i mean they've redesigned
uh the so one of the problems they had
in afghanistan in particular was they
chopped so again you know the original
m16 was designed around a 20-inch barrel
so you're getting 3 200 feet per second
muzzle velocity they chop that down to
16 inches and then
when you're in afghanistan iraq you're
clearing these very small buildings they
needed to be able to maneuver around
corners so they chop the barrels down
even further so now muzzle velocity
you're only getting about 2 600 feet per
second and that's right on the line
where that bullet is going to not tumble
but just pass straight through a target
and so they started to redesign they
went up to uh a 77 grain round made the
bullet heavier
so that it would tumble a little bit
faster they increased the twist rate on
the barrel
they started to play around with now
they have a new version the m855a1 it's
got a steel uh tip at the end uh so it
helps it to pass through particular
barriers and all these things were
tested
on what we saw in afghanistan in the
global war on terror as they cut the
barrels down and they saw yeah you know
two two or five five six got a bad
reputation for a little while because
they were having a lot of pass-throughs
they had designed things to work against
people with body armor they weren't
wearing body armor they weren't tumbling
so they had you know the military
unfortunately is not very good at
like redesigning the whole thing as a as
a package they cut the barrel down they
forget about the ammunition they
redesigned the ammunition they forget
about the rifle and it takes a long time
to get all the way through i think one
thing we're
learning a lot about which most of us
probably already knew um if you're
somebody who knows guns and you guys
infinitely more than the average person
you know all the different reasons for
different bullets all the different
reasons for different barrel lengths and
styles handgun versus rifle heavy barrel
versus you know etc and
what i've come to start you know
realizing is in the past few years when
i've been buying guns and learning about
them when you look at this trial it
really exemplifies how
the average
urban democrat type person thinks all
that exists are ar15s and bullets
they don't realize that like you're
talking about two two three and five
five six they can both be fired out of
five five six but a five five six can't
be in a two two three is correct right
yeah well we're both at for through a
bolt-action rifle yes especially
you would you should not on on a
bolt-out the reason why that happens is
because bolt-action rifles that were
chambered in 223 40 years ago
do not cannot handle the chamber
pressure
of and that is and that is true of 762
and 308. well there's a similar similar
it has it has a lot more i mean there
are more nuances but a major
nuance of that is because of the years
that those bolt action rifles were
popular so 2021
i go to a gun shop i have an uh i was
buying an m1a and
the guy was there's an argument over
whether or not you should load 308 in an
m1a because it was designed for 762 and
they're functional identical rounds but
the higher chamber pressure could be bad
and some guy's telling me a story about
how one gun he saw exploded and then
one's like that never happened you're
lying and they're arguing about it what
the point i'm getting at is
uh there was i i got an argument on
facebook with some guy who was like why
do you need an assault rifle or whatever
and then i'm like you know what i'm not
i'm not an expert but i do know about
the weapons i have and why i have them
and so i just explained like
why the different kind of rounds why the
different kind of shotgun shells or
whatever why the why the different kind
of shotgun and it's like some are better
at close range some are better at medium
range some bullets do one thing or
another and the the issue is that the
world isn't rifle handgun and bullet
right which is what most of these
establishment gun control type people
and and the prosecutor in the ringhouse
case seem to think so i want to get into
the the perfect example of this and we
were talking about it before the show
uh one of the line of quest one of the
questions asked to the prosecutor was
in the moment when gage grosskroitz was
pointing the gun at kyle the prosecutor
said
why did you think he was a threat
right now says because he was
pointing a gun at me and the prosecutor
says he's got a gun in his hand right
yes he could have shot you from 40 50
feet away but he didn't choose to why
did you think that was a threat and
right now just like he was coming at me
with a gun
and this is where i was like they needed
that firearms expert to say
in the heat of a moment
with someone like gage grosskroyce who
is not a firearms expert who's trained
the likelihood of him actually hitting a
target from 50 feet away while running
is slim the night in the dark in the
dark yeah which which would mean
someone who he had a permit before it
was now invalid he knows he won't hit
the target so he's closing the distance
to guarantee the targets in fact that
proves
he was even more dangerous right if he
was trying to shoot from further away
because someone does fire at kyle
written house after the fact you hear
the gunshots kyle just walks slowly away
kyle was not threatened by the fact that
other people had continued shooting
after the fact probably because he's
like they're nowhere near me
but the prosecutor got that question in
and there was no one to rebut it well i
mean it's also
tragic because now that
gage is missing a part of his bicep
we're not going to be able to take him
to a range and see his effectiveness at
40 meters
you know gage grosskroyd's i tweeted
this out i said
people keep uh cheering for this kenosha
guy
who travels you know super far to go to
a riot bring bringing a gun he's not
legally allowed to possess i don't care
if he's claiming he wants to provide
medical assistance or be an emt or
whatever he should not have been there
i'm talking about gage gross corrects of
course not kyle written yes which is
it's interesting that they keep saying
he crossed state lines with an illegal
gun and i'm like gage grosskroyd's
traveled 40 miles than legal gun not
that i think guns should be illegal sure
in this instance like statute well and
engages i mean first of all he's
carrying a 40. so
obviously he doesn't know what he's
doing
um he's on his way
like yeah
uh that's a that's an inside gun joke
anyway
why why nobody uses 40.
it's just kind of an overrated caliber
it it had its time and everybody kind of
jumped on this bandwagon
it's a watered down 10 millimeter
because
the fbi basically invented 10 millimeter
because
there was a couple of bad shootouts they
were involved in so they wanted
something super really really powerful
which 10 millimeter is but then they
found that their agents couldn't handle
the recoil so then they watered it down
and created 40 smith wesson which is the
same bullet a little bit shorter case
less powder
and so for a while it was more powerful
than nine millimeter enough to warrant
it but these days with modern powder and
bullet technology the the difference in
recoil isn't worth the added penetration
the lower magazine capacity the
inability to put two three rounds in the
same hole
all those kinds of things but what i was
getting at with gage is
everybody in this country who concealed
carries a gun on a daily basis knew that
that guy i mean he was a liar obviously
but the minute that that prosecutor said
so you know you carry this gun every day
and he said oh yeah wallet key is gone
every day i leave the house the same way
and the prosecutor said do you know if
you had one in the chamber that night
and he said i don't know
okay everybody knows right we can get
into the debate about should you carry
with one in the chamber or not uh the
answer is yes there is no debate there's
no debate the answer is yes i don't care
about your israeli training or whatever
the answer is yes but the point is even
if you subscribe to the idea that you
shouldn't carry one in the chamber
you at least you know everybody knows
who is at all serious about the fact
that they conceal carry and and uh
having a gun they know whether they have
one in the chamber when you period when
you pick the weapon up you check yeah
when you hand the weapon to somebody
else you check then they check
everybody checks everybody knows and um
the other thing too is i remember
watching this commercial for like
workplace firearms mounting or whatever
it was like i got an ad on facebook for
it and basically
all of it shows that when they're
putting the gun in there it's actually
designed so that you push the gun with
your hand to chamber around under your
desk like what's the point of having a
weapon unready to be used someone kicks
your door in and threatens your life and
you're like give me a minute to you know
there we go all right we're good yeah
and it is it is funny too in the movies
they always always rack the slide yeah
right yeah
speaking of movies and checking your
guns we have alec baldwin
and i mean really at this point in time
they should have called alec baldwin on
the stage to be one of the one because
he would have said no i don't know he
knows what he's talking about he's a
famous hollywood actor
alec baldwin pulled point was handed a
firearm pointed at somebody and pulled
the trigger believing that he was so
holy of a person he couldn't didn't even
have to check i'm i'm sorry you're
incorrect
oh okay you're incorrect what what year
was the movie set to take place and do
you know uh well it's gonna be 1984 it
was like 18 18 uh 1890s i believe okay
1880s um
revolvers back then could you just pull
the trigger
well they're single action only no no
they were single action
my understanding is that it was a single
action
okay the model that he used was a single
action that answered but think about
what that means
not only did he pull a gun and point it
he had to pull the hammer back before
pulling the trigger yeah so this is like
a
look people might think it's nitpicking
but this is literally him making a very
deliberate action to be like not only am
i gonna because some might argue that he
was just going like ah ah you know like
thinking he had an empty you know
cleared cold gun or whatever no no he
pulled the hammer back he was intending
for it to go off right
yeah how that happens
well that's why there's not a lot about
it though this stuff is really important
as i was saying earlier about firearm
terminology in particular uh people
people on the other side think that we
get too caught up in the details but the
details matter i mean when you if you're
a gun owner you almost have to be a
paralegal in a sense because
you saw that in um some of the jury
instructions they were talking about
with rittenhouse with the gun charge
getting basically thrown out you know
the whole thing came down to was he in
possession of a short-barreled rifle or
not well if you ask your average person
what is a short-barreled rifle they
probably wouldn't be able to tell you
but the difference is you know a 16th of
an inch if it's uh 15.9 inches you end
up like randy weaver if it's uh 16
inches you don't so
like
these things matter you know we
this idea that like firearm laws are are
fast and loose
is just nonsense they've they've painted
it to be that way but you have to know
you know is the forward grip uh to you
know just a little bit too long well now
you've got a an aow there's a there's so
so much detail involved thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time